[Musique]
vraiment en termes de stratégie
politique mélenchon c'est quelqu'un qui
part de très loin dans les campagnes
électorales mais habituellement c'est
quelqu'un qui est capable par le fait de
prendre la parole de convaincre parce
qu'il débat bien parce qu'il discours
bien de devenir de plus en plus crédible
au fil de la campagne est donc pour lui
il y avait un vrai enjeu de se lancer
maintenant en attaquant quelqu'un qui
aujourd'hui est plus haut que lui dans
les sondages à côté de ça il y avait un
enjeu qui était plus de relation avec
son camp de base parce que quand on voit
dans le canton voit au niveau de la
manière dont les dents les deux
candidats ont annoncé le fait qu'il
qu'il allait débattre l'un avec l'autre
quand on regarde soul tweet ou mélenchon
annonce qu'il allait débattre avec des
mots y avait beaucoup de gens qu elle
qui disait c'est une erreur il faut pas
débattre avec l'extrême droite parce
qu'il ya dans la partie de mélenchon une
tendance quand celle donc c'est à dire
on ignore plutôt que de débattre et donc
ça veut dire que mélenchon arrivé dans
ce débat avec ce poids supplémentaire
que si c'est pas absolument clair qu'il
a été plus fort que les mots bas il va y
avoir quand même beaucoup de temps dans
son dans son camp qui risque de lui dire
tu aurais pas dû y aller tu lui as donné
une tribune les enjeux au niveau de
zemmour ça le tout le monde l'a compris
également est ce qu'il est capable de
passer d'un point de vue
d'éditorialistes
un point de vue de quelqu'un qui est
capable de débattre de proposer des fins
de faire de la politique en fait donc
pas seulement d'être dans l'analyse et
le diagnostic mais d'être dans la dans
la proposition dans la confrontation de
mesures au réel et l'autre côté c'est
qu'il doit être capable d'être à l'aise
sur une gamme de sujets qui est
peut-être plus vaste que celle qui le
traite habituellement et donc vu que
dans ceux des dents parle également un
petit peu de de géopolitique on parle
également de pouvoir d'achat en parle
également de d'écologie c'était un bon
moyen de voir si zemmour allait se à led
capable d'assumer ce rôle à une première
séance du débat où les journalistes ont
demandé aux deux participants pourquoi
est ce que vous avez décidé d'accepter
zemmour et était dans un rôle habituel
donc c'est à dire bah voila moi je suis
quelqu'un qui considère qu'il faut qu'il
faut discuter toutes les idées et été
très courtois avec son adversaire au
contraire mélenchon s'est lancé dans un
ton tout à fait différent vous êtes en
danger pour notre pays vous avez une
vision rabougrie de la france vous êtes
un raciste vous avez été condamné pour
ça vous êtes un homme qui professait une
vision de la virilité extrêmement
curieuse extrêmement violente c'est vous
qui écrivez que les femmes sont le butin
des hommes vous avez sur les phares une
vision absolument inouïe vous avez week
vous pensez qu elles ont un cerveau
archaïque et et qui n'est pas capable de
formuler des abstractions
musulmans
vous faites le débat avant le débat donc
on sentait dans cette première séquence
du débat son objectif c'était de
rassurer sept bases de son mode histoire
en montrant moment mais je sais bien
qu'en face de moi j'ai le bal en
personne et donc pendant cette première
séquence où bat mélenchon était vraiment
en train de faire un blâme au sens
rhétorique du terme de la personne qu'il
avait en face de lui zemmour était gêné
quand on regarde il avait des petits
rires il avait des petits rires nerveux
c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui ce qui se
faisait tirer l'oreille en fait le
problème c'est que ça s'est vite inversé
parce que mélenchon n'a pas pu garder ce
niveau d'invectivés d'agressivité au
cours du débat et plus le débat avance
est bas plus la relation entre les deux
personnes s'équilibrait et plus du goût
c'était et moore qui marquait des points
lorsque ça voulait dire que en fait on
peut débattre avec lui si on en vient
maintenant à comment est ce que zemmour
s'est sorti des situations dans
lesquelles il abordait des sujets qui à
priori était passée où il était le plus
à l'aise et bien je trouve qu'il a été
il a des très judicieux et que mélenchon
s'est peut-être fait un peu avoir parce
que qu'est-ce qui s'est passé quand ils
ont parlé d'écologie je n'ai pas dit que
vous disiez que c'est à dire compris et
surtout son père meurt aujourd'hui c'est
bien aussi si on peut revenir à
aujourd'hui aux solutions pour
aujourd'hui seulement 0 au départ sont
de gauche vous savez mais c'est une
discussion qui nous mènerait trop loin
donc nous avons donc que c'est pas les
mains il faut dire aux idéologies jeu ce
qu'ils n'avaient pas les libéraux
économies s'ils étaient liés mais non
des libéraux dans l'autoritarisme les
libéraux
lle derrière louis philippe et vous le
savez pas quel wifi on va parler de
maintenant mais justement zemmour a
toujours su ramener les sujets à des
îles est montée en généralité pour
toujours ramener ça à des enjeux soient
l'immigration soit souveraineté
nationale donc il a été capable
d'occuper le terrain sur son terrain
alors que c'était plutôt des sujets qu a
priori mélenchon maîtrisait il est parti
dans des digressions historiques sur le
fait que l'écologie on dit que c'est une
tradition de gauche mais peut-être que
c'est une tradition de droite et tout ce
temps de parole et était occupé à faire
ce qui fait habituellement de la théorie
et de l'histoire de l'historial isme
finalement est passé du temps que
mélenchon n'a pas plus utilisée pour
marquer lui c'est qu'il aurait dû garder
cette posture plus longuement donc le
fait que c'est un homme d'état il sait
comment ça marche un processus de de
faire passer des lois il sait ce que
c'est que la confrontation d'une mesure
aurait elle il aurait dû plus adoptée se
bat ce niveau de discours là mais il
s'est toujours fait remarquer avec des
mots parce que lui aussi il aime bien
l'histoire il aime bien la théorie donc
si on parlait de concepts créolisation
et c'est donc mélenchon c'est un peu
trop fait embarquer sur le terrain
zemmour est donc ça ce qui fait qu'on
n'a pas eu cette confrontation on aurait
pu espérer des bas des mesures de
zemmour aurait elle
là où je donnerai des points par contre
à mélenchon c'est au niveau des
conclusions zemmour est resté là pour le
coup dans son rôle d'éditorialiste donc
qu'est ce qui a fait le succès des mots
est bien c'est qu'il est capable comme
ça de donner à son public du constat
noire il y aura plus de pauvreté plus de
misère et surtout plus de désordre plus
de violence comme ce qui se passe
actuellement ça montera crescendo parce
que tout simplement
le peuple aura été petit à petit le
peuple français aura été petit à petit
remplacer par un autre top
en 2050 vous aurez simplement vous savez
c'est déjà monsieur mélenchon vous
pouvez rire à savoir une gamme
d'émotions très noir très négative donc
quelqu'un qui fait un diagnostic
quelqu'un qui fait un constat ça c'est
une position d'éditorialistes c'est une
position de quelqu'un qui vend des
livres c'est pas une position de meneur
d'hommes
c'est une position de dealers d'opinion
c'est pas une position de leader
d'opinion alors que mélenchon quand
mélenchon prend la parole lui on pense
qu'on veut du fond de son discours mais
quand mélenchon prend la parole c'était
un discours d'espoir et de détermination
il a parlé d' esprit français l'esprit
français c'est pas un esprit qui
s'abaisse l'esprit français c'est un
esprit scientifique y trouve des mesures
qui perdent qui parvient à se dépasser
et c'est pourquoi est ce que c'est
important d'arriver à cette gamme
d'émotions qui peinent gamme d'émotions
négatives mais une gamme d'émotions
positives parce que le rôle d'un
politique c'est pas seulement de ceux
des diagnostics c'est d'avancer des
mesures et d'enclencher ce fonds publics
fait son public des leviers émotionnelle
comme la détermination comme la fierté
comme le courage qui permettent de
passer à l'action donc là je suis pas en
train de faire un jugement sur le fond
des discours mais vraiment au niveau
rhétorique
zemmour n'a pas encore toute la gamme
dont on a besoin pour être capable de
passer de la critique à la mobilisation
et la galvanisation du public donc pour
dire les choses très simplement je
dirais que zemmour a gagné sur le plan
dialectique parce qu'il a été capable
d'emmener son d'emmener son adversaire
là où il le voulait il a été capable le
plus souvent d'occuper le terrain comme
il le voulait mais mélenchon gagne
encore au plan rhétorique c'est à dire
c'est un meilleur tri l'un ça mais entre
humains c'est quelqu'un qui est encore
plus capable de galvaniser les foules